hi I'm Eyal I'm speaking from London I
am an applied machine learning scientist
at Zimmer biomed a medical manufacturing
device manufacturer and I will talk
about p-values which are perhaps the the
most popular metric to assess the
significance of a signal within data and
today I'm going to present a few
uncomfortable truths about it in
particular I've been wondering I had an
uneasy feeling why is it that we can use
it to reject the null hypothesis but
never to accept it and so I'm not
assuming you know what p-values are but
you probably heard about them being
mentioned when somebody mentions the
significance of a signal and so I'll
introduce what they are and then the
main topic is why can't we use them to
accept the null hypothesis I'll then
talk about virtues and advices and how
we can ultimately do better a bit about
me I've been doing that analysis for uh
over 15 years now started off as an
astronomer and most recently in the
health
within the health sector so p-values are
a way of quantifying how extreme your
observed data is
considering your underlying null
hypothesis and this is useful because
you can use uh to you could potentially
use this to reject a null hypothesis if
you think that your data is too extreme
um
compared to that null hypothesis so I
could describe this in in in equations
but I prefer to use uh visuals and so
let's imagine a case of tossing a coin
10 times and your observable is that it
landed
um with eight successes or heads so
assuming that the coin you think that
the coin is fair you have no other
reason
to think otherwise
um we want to test how we want we use
key value to quantify how extreme it is
and so you can think of um here's the
distribution of what you'd expect a
binomial distribution of unexpect from
10 classes of a coin where uh no
um the y-axis is the logarithm of the uh
of the probability the reason is I want
to highlight These Wings over here and
the meaning of the color coding is
everything in white is kind of uh um
everything in white is between three
tosses three successes to seven but then
your Observer your your observed data is
at eight right so in the p-value what
we're doing we're we're going to sum
over all the all of the probability from
eight and more extreme so that means
eight nine and ten but also on the other
side something called a two-sided test
because we didn't know which way we're
going to be extreme otherwise it's
something called the what what one-sided
test so what we do is we sum up all
these red bars and what we get is a
p-value of 11 so is that considered
extreme should we uh rule out the notes
hypothesis well most likely not around
11 is not that extreme what you want
what you normally want to do if you can
budget for it you want to collect more
data so this is uh just a simulation so
we can obviously do that so multiply
this both times three so let's do
everything times three and we have the
same ratio 24 divided by 30 is the same
as 8 divided by 10 but the p-value
actually goes down by two orders of
magnitude from 11 to 0.14 that means if
we have a fair coin the probability of
getting 24 heads given 30. tosses is
much more extreme and that gives us much
more confidence to reject the null
hypothesis so so most of you already
know this but what I was wondering is
why in all the textbooks they mentioned
that we can use it to reject the null
hypothesis but again not to accept it
for example Bayesian methods
um you can be used to accept it so
actually I wasn't Pi data London earlier
this year and the statistician told me
that actually he heard recently about an
answer what I call a semi
semi-satisfactory answer is that the
probability of the p-value in these
cases uh in the case in which you can't
accept potentially is is as probable of
being lower than 10 percent than it is
being higher than 90 I thought that's
interesting and it's something I can
quickly code up and test for myself and
see what these sort of distributions
look like and so in order to do so I
continued tossing more virtual coins and
I set up an experiment that I'll
describe now in which uh before what we
did is we tossed one a coin we did one
experiment of let's say 30 classes and
we got one p-value now I'm going to run
thousands of simulations in which I'm
going to cost first I'm going to cost a
Fair coin and unfair coin and something
in between uh and we're going to assume
a null hypothesis of 0.5 and we have the
luxury of knowing the ground truth in
real life you don't have that but this
is going to test like The credibility of
p-values in terms of accepting the
null's hypothesis which which we know
what it is over here and so
um we're going to start where um we're
going to start with the unfair coin so
we do thousands of experiment and each
experiment we toss a coin 256 times now
and then we get uh um for each
series of 256 we get one p-value but we
do this thousands of time and so I can
draw this distribution but what I did is
I bend the P values into bins of 10 so
between 0 to 10 10 to 20
Etc and so what you can read here is
that if you toss a coin to 156 times uh
the probability of rejecting the null
hypothesis which is the correct thing to
do you can do that only 50 of the time
what's the solution well either make a
decision with you know low confidence or
just if you get more budget you can
collect more coins and so that's what
we'll do we'll have let's say we'll have
a budget of multiply times sixteen four
thousand one hundred tosses then you
have full confidence a hundred percent
of time you'll reject the null
hypothesis uh so that's that's great
when you have a lot of signal let's say
0.55 but if you have slightly less
signal let's say a slightly biased at
0.52 suddenly you see that uh even with
this High budget you can reject eighty
percent of the time because you can
start seeing like this tail growing so
again either you you set more budget
which is
not realistic or you have to make a
decision with low confidence
but what happens if the underlying
ground truth is a Fair coin well the
interesting thing in the free accordion
is that we get a flat distribution
there's no way to distinguish between 10
and 90 in terms of
um which way is it going uh and so I
thought that the semi-satisfactory
answer that I got before can eat one can
even make a stronger statement in which
the p-values have no acceptance signal
at all and so I thought that's pretty
interesting and worth sharing for those
who are interested in these geeky
details of Statistics because I don't
see it I didn't see it anywhere in the
literature I call it a semi-satisfactory
answer because it's very anecdotal using
simulations I tested it only for
binomial distributions but I'm sure that
there is a mathematical solution
somewhere uh if somebody could point out
that to me that's great but I did a few
searches I couldn't find anything uh and
so
uh should you continue to use p-values
well most likely both you and I are
going to do it for this a simple reason
that it's easy to calculate it's highly
familiar uh but um
but that said one should take results
with a grain of salt because first of
all p-values are not understood by
non-experts it causes a lot of confusion
especially this double negative that
they're talking about the fact that you
can't use to accept it but only not
reject you always want to avoid double
negatives uh there is even stronger
statement in the literature by
statistician that I like called John
krusk in which he claims that if you use
the p-values to decide when to stop
collecting data during a null hypothesis
he claims that if the underlying uh um
if the null hypothesis is the underlying
truth actually with enough time the null
hypothesis statistical test will always
have will have a hundred percent false
positives so that's a very strong
statement that it makes to explain it
requires two or three minutes uh in
which I have visuals but it's beyond the
time the lightning talk but
um but basically you can think of it
like The Emperor's New Clothes in which
p-value is still King we're all using it
but those uh but people go like maybe
also you know are very cautious about
how we work like uh our interpretation
of it because there are people like John
Cruz I was taking taking a snapshot of
him like pointing out at Major flaws
that the statistic has well can we do
better
um we can do better because we can use
Vision statistics
um
that has quite a lot of overhead uh but
it's and that's the reason to go to use
uh p-values because of the overhead uh
of Beijing but and if you can use
Beijing then it's preferred uh and so
why can why did I say that patients uh
can accept another hypothesis where the
frequencies p-values cannot the main
idea is because the difference in
philosophy uh so the frequentists who
use the p-values rely on likelihoods uh
remember I said that it's the
probability of the data assuming the
null hypothesis that's how you read this
conditional probability as opposed to
the bayesians who use uh a different
approach use posters what's the
probability of hypothesis given the data
so hence you're much more flexible at
your interpretation
um if you're interested in this topic uh
um I'll be checking and put a plugin for
my talk tomorrow
um I got it I got interested in this
topic because I was learning about uh
how do you decide
um that you collected enough data for uh
you know hypothesis and so I'll talk
about the limitations and actually flaws
in the common practices or both
frequentest and Bayesian and uh I'll
highlight this underrated uh
unappreciated method called Precision is
the goal in which puts front and center
um the aspect of uh stating in advance
how how precise do you want to be in
your measurement before even collecting
the data and that way can ensure robust
results so so check out London time
tomorrow at nine o'clock so to summarize
um what what um I want to communicate
today p-values cannot be used to accept
the null hypothesis because it doesn't
contain any signal that's what we saw in
this chart over here and if you want a
mechanism to accept the null hypothesis
then you want to go Bayesian uh thank
you